you
hello on a very warm welcome to this
latest edition of talking Germany the
show where we do just that and we are
today going to be focusing on why it is
so very difficult for women to make it
into the higher echelons of German
business and to help us find some
answers my guest today is the head of
Germany's Association of women
entrepreneurs and here she is Stephanie
sure thank you thank you for joining us
here in Berlin today now Stephanie be
sure I'd like to you know begin by
asking you the most obvious question of
all your head of the Women's Association
or the association of female
entrepreneurs in Germany why does
Germany need such an association
catering specifically to female
entrepreneurs yeah because we are still
um the taillight I think you're saying
English in the European comparison um
from female entrepreneurs in leading
positions and or from females in leading
positions and I think a very important
thing for females in or four women in
Germany is also networking you know
we're not really used to it too much
because the guys have like 300 years in
advance so and we have to make up for
that and um to be within an atmosphere
where you have only female entrepreneurs
and you have the same problem and the
same subjects makes it very easy yeah
and I mean you talked about the problem
immediately there that we're going to be
focusing on today in Germany when you go
into the into them into the internet
when you when you and it totally in the
media the one of the biggest problems is
the glass ceiling we often hear about
Germany and the glass ceiling though
they go almost hand in hand for women at
least and this glass ceiling in Germany
it's very hard it's very low and it's
very thick yeah how does it feel for
women here in Germany to be hitting
their head against that glass ceiling
all the time well maybe it I have to
specify here because female
entrepreneurs obviously do not have that
feeling because they just decided they
wanted to be chefs and they did it and
we don't have a glass ceiling obviously
in our firms because we are you know
leading them so I think the problem is
with the big like ducks businesses and
then blue chip companies there you
definitely do have it and some
why is it that way I try to find the
answer for the past five or ten years
and I think a big thing is just the
social role models that we have here in
Germany you know it's still the debt is
earning the money and the mummy is
tending the kids which is great but why
is that why is it like that in Germany
and we're always hearing about the
Scandinavian countries in Germany is
very traditional in the Scandinavian
countries it's so much more progressive
what is the explanation for that well
because the next thing is that everybody
keeps telling us some we're very
economically a very successful country
why should we change anything that's the
first thing and that the next thing is
some my answers yeah it works fine so we
don't really feel the need yet you know
because maybe the last of Labor the lack
of flavors not really has hit the
country that badly and the next
explanation I mean I don't really have
it but maybe it's the idea um to talking
in a bad ya face in our history that was
a naughty you know I'm kind of like role
model to where she didn't work and you
know the guys working and the housewife
is just you know forming a nice home and
being um yeah the post and you're
suggesting that there is still something
of that model that has not quite been
eradicated in Germany that is still part
of German society I think that we still
have um yeah I mean we are the only
country in the world who have that word
of a motor you know for ladies who
decide not only to turn their kids but
also to work and why is it that way I
mean this all the questions I I don't
really have to explain I mean a very
interesting word that effort folk for
women who do go back to work as you're
saying very quickly after having having
a child people say since she's a robin
but if she's around what she's not
looking after her children enough
properly and it's very accusatory it is
it's very negative it's very negative no
it's not that we have the feeling that
we really have to thoroughly think of
how little hours of a mother my kid
needs and I has two hands and
yeah and I have so many friends like in
France are in the UK where it's a
completely the other way around you get
looked at if you don't go back to work
after you had your child you know um if
I'm right there but that's what they
keep telling me you know it's that's how
the system works and that's how
everybody thinks about it you know so
that's very different okay we're talking
about women banging their heads against
the glass ceiling we're talking about
women being called Robin murder this
German word we're talking about still a
within the air of the way that women
were viewed in the dark days of the Nazi
regime in your association in your
circle of friends how angry do women get
about the state of affairs I think we do
most of us do get angry because it would
be great to have just more and more
qualified a kindergarten for example you
know where we have a better ratio
between the kids and the educator there
and the nurse you know so that is one
point and we think that that subject a
lot of my friends think that that
subject could you know we need more of
political engagement there ok there's a
lot that we've good that we can talk
about you've had your first impressions
there from Stephanie be sure here is
more
Stephanie pushers hobby is sailing
whenever she has time she takes to the
water in this discipline skill and
experience count more than muscle power
Saigon fatigue is a strategic sport it's
often said that sailing is chess on the
water if you can think strategically you
have a definite advantage I water when
she's not out navigating her boat
attorney Stephanie runs an auditing firm
in Berlin together with two partners
today an internal training session is
about to begin Stephanie pusher employs
70 people vanish f'n as a woman the
prospective and insights as boss are
different to that of a man swishing
mention of expenditure sure also puts
our energy into her presidency of the
Association of German women
entrepreneurs even today four out of
five companies have men only management
what women need is not so much training
as contacts s sure this is he thinking
where give afloat investing this book
water visiting clients is crucial to
those contacts this client likewise
heads a midsize company in Berlin in her
case in the male-dominated world of car
dealerships the two women got to know
each other via the entrepreneurs
association which is now lobbying for
the introduction of gender quotas for
Germany's boardrooms wat SI anna &
loveless and its president is fully
behind that fight in lines all today
the mother of two children also wants to
see family-friendly working hours that's
not easy in her sector and today she's
our guest on talking Germany Stephanie
pshaw definitely sure to just tell us we
began that report by seeing you in your
boat they're seeing you out sailing
which is one of your great passions tell
us what that passion tells us about you
I'm it tells you about me that I love to
be outside and then I think I'm being in
nature and especially being in a
different medium like on the different
meeting me like water gets you out of
stressful situations makes you open your
mind again makes you help deciding or
finding good decisions and you just
you're really out of your daily
procedures that's what I like so much
about it I wonder when did you start
sailing is it is it something that you
began in Berlin because it's a i think a
lot of people it's a sport that's very
much associated with Berlin I think
people be surprised to hear that because
we have so much water it's amazing it's
yes yes I think when people think of
Berlin they think of the city that used
to have the Berlin Wall and now has a
trendy downtown right but there are all
these wonderful lakes yeah sec um tell
me a little bit about how you where you
grew up because you didn't grow up in
Berlin and how you grew up I grew up
close to Cologne and I grew up in a very
um I'd say yeah open house hold my
mother already back in the 60s took a
year leaf in the USA I have a lot of
family all over the world for example in
Argentina Buenos Aires in in all the
East Coast in America my family sits and
so yeah we were always educated all
three of us I have a brother and a
sister and all three of us some really
were M encouraged to discover the world
and we traveled a lot as a family we
solve for example we did the Rocky
Mountains with a camper all together and
in you know Canada and yeah a lot of
Europe and we did a lot by current my
parents always said some it's a one of
the most important education ziff you
trouble it sounds absolutely wonderful
and I can see how it has made you the
person you are I just like to ask you
though because you're mentioning
yourself you mentioning your brother
yeah were you encouraged because you use
the word encouraged in the same way as
your brother as a girl because that's
very important for the person you've
become as well definitely I was
encouraged in the same way i'm the
oldest so I was the first to decide
whether or not i study at all and if yes
what do I study and that was one of the
I think best tips my father ever gave me
because I I love languages and I wanted
to study languages and then he made that
remark why don't you think about
combining it because some you know
language is a very useful but maybe you
do something different and that's how I
came too long let's talk about the world
of work the world of business you run
your own business and we had a comment
from one of the one of your staff
members in the report that we just seen
he a man said as a woman your
perspective and insight as a boss are
different to that as a man he said it
almost as a sort of a generalization hey
this is it a valid generalization well
you know what I think it's there is not
really it's not a valid generalization I
think yes men and women are different
but more important I think personalities
are so different you know gender leaving
alone letter letting alone gender em and
what he might think is some the only
thing that I think might differ in most
women and men is maybe the team aspect
um so that women tend to kind of like
get the team together a little more than
deciding on their own and giving their
employees I'm the feeling okay we're
really creating hear something together
and I think a lot of men will just
brought up that way that being a chef
means I know everything and I can do
everything and I cannot ever um you know
tell my employees I don't know right now
and I have to look it up or something
like that and maybe um women have a less
problem with that a fact a different
style of management for men paradiddles
if we don't want to generalize what what
about the difficult words power and
authority are these are these things
that women have to learn to deal with
and no no no I think you either have it
or you don't and I think the most
important thing to be in authority and
and to be seen as long as that you're
authentic and if as long as you are that
and as long as you have either fun to
you know make decisions and then stick
to them and really be able to explain
them and not you know go like back and
white back and forth like we say I'm
finching in vinton German just how would
you just like that blowing in the way
yeah changing your mind all the time I
think these are important aspects of
having Authority or not mmm you
mentioned at the beginning that a lot of
the women you represent a women who have
effectively set up their own companies
is that one way for women to escape the
pressures of being in a male-dominated
work environment yeah maybe it's not an
escape but just another possibility you
know to fulfill your life three more the
idea of your life you know it's
completely different I think if you're
one of you know in the management of a
blue chip company and you leave after
four or seven years and doesn't really
matter and how many people you dismiss
within that time but as an entrepreneur
you have the full responsibility for
your employees you have your own money
in their company it's completely
different it's completely different form
of responsibility and I think either men
or woman you have to decide if that is
the word in the life they want to be
leaning and is it more difficult for
women to set up their own companies in
Germany I mean you made you there was
the example again in that report of you
you went down to your bang bang yeah you
said oh I want to take out a loan and
they said well let's speak to your
husband yep yeah yeah representative is
that at the climate I think it is I'm
still pretty representative but then
again I think the world is changing
their the bank's really realized that
females are just as well a client here
for them in an interesting Clinton
that's a few a lot of females set of
businesses um you know because yeah they
can be their own boss and maybe it's a
form of avoiding that ceiling that we
were talking about it's a very positive
picture in a lot of ways that your book
I mean obviously you interact with a lot
of women who have who are successful in
business we're successful already yeah
who are successful successful in
business in the broadest sense
nevertheless I must say that I quite
often speak to women in Germany who in
not just in my business in the media but
in a broader sense who are successful
women who will however say in a quiet
moment that they are that they the a
problem for them in advancing in their
careers is is perhaps a problem that men
don't have in quite the same way and
you're wondering what i'm going to say
in area but I'm ever you guessing yet is
the problem of doubt self down yes I'll
women agree I agree if I'm being asked
what could we changed I always say don't
try to be male stick to your female
being a butt maybe we do need a little
self marketing this does not mean you
know include bragging about yourself not
in that aspect but just to to be more ya
self sure of that what you're doing and
that you um that is perfectly okay if
you want to you know have your own
career and try and to divide that within
your being a mother and tending to your
kids and maybe even get your partner
more into that business you know so that
you're really sharing that
responsibility for your joint children
are you were feminist no no no no what
is a feminist for me if a feminist is
someone or maybe I'll go back a step I
mean I took over my other my menu yeah
position for for you I said you know
what girls we are all agree on the
subjects that we need more female
leaders but we need the men and I say
the only way we be successful here is
you know persuading them in and dumb I
think I mean not not at all the feminist
I like to listen and I'll i fear i find
it especially interesting to listen and
to discuss this subject with men because
i think they are the ones we need to
persuade for of the importance of all
these quarter and whatever in our
country and so now for me a feminist as
someone who was you know way more
radical and without the understanding of
the position of men would tell me some
of them really do have the problem to
find women appropriate women
appropriately qualified for their
positions and I do know from my own
experience even if I'm you know now
going to a different as aspect that a
lot of women don't even you
they don't want to be leaders and I
perfectly satisfied with what they're
doing in their job and they love it and
they don't need to be the boss but just
perfectly well maybe some of those are
feminists as well though know you
mentioned Jeff anyone interesting word
there which was quota we're gonna be
talk about a quota because it's a fact
there's no doubt about it the number of
women in top positions in Germany's
leading companies is shockingly low the
question is how do you solve the problem
some say the answer is what the Germans
call a fro unquote a gender quota that
would ensure that women are more fairly
represented but not everybody agrees
including some women my new level so has
achieved something that many women dream
of she's on the supervisory board the
major German company pause I women need
to decide what they want they need to
take on responsibility and they have to
articulate what they want I've had
positive experience doing that of her on
gamma but Russo is an exception because
female executives are rare in Germany
only fourteen percent of dax listed
companies have women at boardroom level
in a country where over fifty percent of
university graduates are female so
what's preventing women from taking on
managerial roles you mocked igual night
we can use habits the tendency to
recruit on common ground in the admins
men will initially get along better with
another man than a woman in video it's
the fall and a fat male applicant also
went to the same university in electric
or you worked well with him on another
committee then you'll naturally choose
that man needs a definitive tease money
women don't stand a chance under those
circumstances and are from the outset
not even considered as potential
candidates
the solution is a female quota Manila
Rizzo believes the reason so few women
have become top managers in Germany is
because of gender role perceptions stop
today we have legacy practices as
regards roles between men and women and
they put us a long way from the world of
equal opportunities ago sociologist bada
event off believes there yet more
problems women who do become directors
pay a heavy price many have to make the
choice of either family or career benzi
boobies applies if you really want to be
successful in a job that's very
demanding yeah and if you also want to
care for your children properly then the
point comes when you realize that you
can't do both when you buy a gun dish an
iron pund with Suzanne is shaft asleep
germies politicians business leaders and
corporate structures need to change if
they don't female company managers will
remain the exception and not the norm
Stephanie be sure you are a fervent
supporter of the of the quota the gender
go to the throwing quarters they say in
Germany just explain from your
perspective why because um I think it
has been 20 years since we tried to do
something in between it's not a legal
quota but rather that different
companies would you know have an aspect
of doing a quarter within their own
conscience resolution exactly thank you
and that didn't really lead through any
major differences and I just think we
should not wait another one or two
generations 20 or 40 years to really
have a fair um yeah what's wrong I had
again equality opportune of
opportunities in this country you know
and um I also think that the quarter
could be a measurement and even if we
only have it for like five years what
exactly do you want forty percent or T
we should ask for board members to start
with and in the German ya leading
companies until 2018 mm-hmm and are you
gonna get it um I hope
to a let's talk about angler Merkel here
because we're talking you're talking
about rules and regulations in to help
women yes make it into the top level of
management Angela Merkel the German
Chancellor has shown that he didn't need
that she's got all the way and there are
other there are other people other women
in politics as well that's what do you
say to that yeah but those are their
soul role models you know they're
they're just the exhaust or exotic
person sound they're the exceptions that
proves the rule maybe yeah exactly and
you know even if you see on the
companies that are state-owned Berlin is
a very good example just a new statistic
of daughter Institute River shut for
Sean showed yeah we have a very good
quarter there but a lot of other states
in Germany it's a tour terrible there a
lot of state-owned companies that don't
have one female in the board of them
that this shows me decision makers so
you know I think politics have to really
stop a hat okay you have met Chancellor
Merkel yes yeah I did yeah and and yeah
I mean she is she's very lukewarm to put
it mildly about the quota yeah you're
not you're a supporter did you have a
conversation about you know that
honestly the time was too short but out
of two or three of her remarks when she
gave her big speech on our last
convention I think um if if she was
really true um maybe you know letting
politics aside and she would also see
that there's an importance and we I
spoke to mr. gawk our mmm the federal
president right and for 30 minutes
together with six other I'm Association
representatives and after and he was
completely against the quarter and said
his daughter also and after we left the
biggest compliment was that he said um
well maybe you really gave me for the
first time some very good arguments for
it oh yeah that's why we left so you
know you just need to talk about it yeah
but one aspect of the whole debate that
we're talking about here that came up in
the report which i think is very very
painful for a lot of women is that a lot
of successful women in Germany according
to the report and I think it's true from
you know
anecdotally from what I know a lot of
women to be successful have forgone the
possibility of having children how much
do you talk about that in your
association how big is the phenomenon I
think I'm the most eighty percent I'd
probably say of our female entrepreneurs
and which are over thousand members in
Germany now they do have children so
they both combined it they all combined
it or most of them combined it but I
think you're right especially if we come
to the leading companies probably due to
you know working hours and travelling me
to travel a lot which is still very
difficult if you have a husband at the
same time might do the same or something
comparable mmm if we have more women in
top levels of business and management
would we work less no no no I don't
think so I mean it might sound like a
ridiculous question but said but but
somewhere you know we have to it's about
getting the right balance yeah that's
and women know more about getting the
right balance or not having the right
balance because they've been the people
who've tried to who've tried to have a
career and have children have families
at the same time that's very true but
when I am just for my own the job
interviews the hundreds of job
interviews I did in the last ten years
and my own company I'd say that's that's
not a gender specific subject the
work-life balance is for both my female
and my male employees a big subject
which is all right i mean it's different
from what we kind of like pro rise but
that's I think it's the right way and
there is more to life than work I
totally agree as a father of two yeah I
in in recent years i have often stood
right in front of men who are in senior
management or who run big companies or
medium-sized companies here in germany
and they've done this they've been
wringing their hands and they've been
saying i would like to have many more
women in senior positions but i can't
find them you've heard this of many
times before one of my I'm and the best
arguments are to encounter so to speak
because we have one of those programs
where
or have a data banks with a 500 female
yeah females in that could tomorrow you
know take over some board how do you say
so they're equipped they're trained
they're absolutely capable of taking up
a position on a supervisory board and a
big German got the only thing that
drives were 900 yes my only thing that
they might not have is the experience of
form Board Association and so if you
know if you say I desperately need
someone who has experience in that field
then there's this you know typical death
circle where you never get out because
how can you get experience if you never
get one mandate good that's not possible
good question good question okay I'll
say it again Germany is a progressive
country and one that is largely very
efficient although we should not get
carried away because the education
system is in many ways a bit of a mess
as a result far too many children don't
get the attention they need and as a
result they get left behind this bunch
of fourth graders in Berlin dreams big
dreams then she plans on being a nurse
when she grows up there this boy wants
to be a footballer and this voy a doctor
becoming a teacher is this girl's goal
those dreams depend on getting a good
education many kids from poor families
fail to complete secondary school Berlin
school system is better at this than
Bavaria's the education differences
between Germany states can be large kids
in Bavaria for example tend to have
better grades when they leave school
than children from Berlin who are among
the worst performers nationwide uke
tiger from the bertelsmann foundation
says the solution to this is well known
already important individually we need
to focus more on individual support for
pupils there are huge differences within
the classroom there won't be progress if
you try to drive everyone forward at the
same pace
but not every state in Germany can
afford that with funding in short supply
in the German capital teacher pay is
very low by national standards zashley
sure ocean you have to have enough
personnel and enough teaching it coupons
that should not depend on where child
grows out liable does but it shouldn't
depend on a state's budget hole fights
it ours Indian Island and Lynn nod when
it comes to Germany's performance grades
it must improve a child's future is
determined by education and in Germany
at least we're that schooling takes
place there's a lot we could talk about
here you are an entrepreneur what can
you tell us about the young men and
women who are coming out of Germany's
schools a lot of people say you know the
standard is not good enough well I'd say
um when I compare um you know education
in other European countries for example
i think the standard is good here and
the only thing that i would agree to is
that we could maybe you need some more
practical experience within the
education and maybe for some jobs some
more international education but as far
you know as my job interviewers they all
went to another country and that months
or years of being outside of germany so
maybe that tells us that the German
education system is a little bit of a
sort of a class system because there are
the kids at the top of the system who
are coming out who are very very well
qualified and there are the kids
mentioned in that report who are being a
little bit neglected a little bit left
behind and maybe there's a there's a
class divided there and certainly I mean
you will know as a parent I think it's
important for people to understand the
German education system to know that
there's a real there's a cut off in the
German education system there are kids
who go forward to hire schooling what
they call the Gunners aamir the grammar
school yeah and kids who don't yeah
right and I think um that's based on on
the subject that education is not only
school and not only school can be made
responsible for that and so definitely
yes your background is part of it and if
you just not encouraged you know from
home to start reading and stop watching
television or you know try to start to
interest yourself or something else but
and some peers that I game or something
like that then yes
you do have a problem and so it's part
of the parents to you know and they
hardly sometimes they hardly even speak
our language so ocean they encourage a
kid mmm-hmm that's a problem hmm and it
is interesting that the politician tell
me a little bit again from your
perspective as a parent that there's a
lot there is a lot of dissatisfaction in
Germany with the education system and an
awful lot I find I find with my kids
going through the education system where
people would often say it's a bit of a
mess it's not really working and then
they turn to politics and say politics
should be doing something about it but
it wasn't happening yeah what's
happening too much you know we had so
many reforms and nobody really without
even having the chance for the first
reform for example you know to take you
to be into action and to just
experiences for 23 years and see how
everybody could work with it the kids
and the teachers and so on so I think
one big favor for our system could be
stop stop reforming anything and the
next thing I think is some we should
change that the whole organization of it
because it can be that all 16 countries
you know do their own education system
and that makes it hard even to move not
outside of this country but rather with
in this country to a different state and
then try to find the school for you kid
I think that's definitely a circumstance
we need to change okay so a strong
element of regionalism in the German
system very typical for Germany just
just how give me one word because again
as an employer I'm very interested about
Germany's vocational education system
because it certainly outside gender-
it's viewed as absolutely legendary
Germany's training system of training
young people up for for for applied work
in companies in industry is that still
as good as it was in you know ten years
ago um I think so yeah and vocal system
is a vocational system yeah what
training training young people up for
specifically for specific jobs I'm like
em hun tak like you know for example
yeah yeah yeah I think I'm isn't it that
we have one of our really good exports
ideas as the dwellers esteem module
system yeah and i think that's that's a
very good system i think to to combine
that we have quite a bit
so you know had that education and I
think as I said the practical aspect is
what I think is so important about it
because that makes you just more fit for
a practical work theory is one thing and
you definitely need it but I think
especially also in my business field
it's large it's learning by doing you
know and so I'm to get also the young
people a better idea of what they might
be good at because and what they might
like later on as a profession would be
great if they have more opportunity to
train that on to try that out hmm
that looks like a very nice view her
office no office looked very lovely too
but the view from up on the top of the
the top of the dome have you been up
there yeah mm-hmm certainly certainly
yeah can you take people up there and
then and allow them to enjoy the view
with you you can organize something and
up there and anywhere in the dome oh if
you want to but it's very busy um-hmm to
admit so you know with all the concerts
and everything okay my place luckily I
must tell you however that I'm a little
bit skeptical about the dorm I've never
really been able to develop a huge
amount of enthusiasm for the building
and you're associated with it can you
win my heart for it um I think first
thing you need to know which I didn't
know before I started that position is
that it needs eleven thousand euros a
day in order to be restored properly and
you know to stay as a billing as it is
and that's a lot of money and what I
also learned is only like four percent
come from church taxes from that and the
rest just needs to be the entree and
things like that and I think that is
just an outstanding building from the
architectural point of view and also
from you know its position within the
city and um I I just like my new home
berlin and that's why i decided okay
let's do something for some part of it
what is your role exactly in the church
there well i'm part of that I'm part of
them yeah kind of like the management of
mr. strongest again the foundation
foundation yeah who try to raise money
and to support different subjects or
projects and in restoring the dome for
example mmm are you successful I'm is
slowly very slowly starting and getting
there it's um we were only founded in
2009's so um yeah it's it's as you said
it's uh it looks like a perfectly you
know healthy building and nothing wrong
with it and so it's really hard to
persuade people that the dome actually
needs money um so yeah it's just a I
think mouth to mouth thing and some mmm
it'll take some time definitely you're
talking about the fact that this sort of
the enthusiasm isn't isn't quite as warm
as maybe you would want how important is
the church in Germany today I know that
sounds like a very big question but I'd
like to ask you because I think it is an
important question it is an important
question I fully agree and I but I think
for the most of the people it's not
important because we had so much bad
press and I mean which is right because
the circumstances we don't need to
elongate now but definitely called for
it and so um maybe with a new pope who I
think gives us a completely different
picture of how he intends to lead the
church in this world maybe we have a
little turnaround as you'd say in the
management that's that's absolutely
fascinating somebody who is a member of
germany's evangelical protestant church
say saying that your plans even it yeah
you don't remember but you're
financially involved yeah hmm hmm not
financially though no I do I know in
terms of the foundation yeah well let me
just pick up them let me go one stage
further I mean because you're somebody
who's involved in the church as we've
seen your also somebody who's involved
in business and commerce and we've we're
still in the throes of the financial
crisis where an awful lot of people lost
their moral compass yeah what would your
comment on that be coming from those two
perspectives now I think I'm that we the
meaning to maybe we focus a little bit
in this country I'm again and I'm first
of all I think from talking to for
example to all the female entrepreneurs
and my association I think be yeah they
look very positive into the future and
we don't really see it that we are still
kind of like the victim of any crisis
here so in Germany so and the next thing
is that I think we should promote maybe
you know a little bit from the role
model in the US where a lot of people do
charity and a lot more than in Germany
to get ya an idea of that our society
needs charity and that we need to yeah
maybe start next from taking
responsibility for our own companies and
employees but for something else you
know in our society so I think that's
what I meant
by refocusing a little bit wise
wonderful words we've just got a minute
for you to tell us about you brought
something along for us today except
Ernie yeah tell us about the camera
that's lying between us yeah yeah it's
important to you yeah it's important to
you because it's one of my my favorite
hobbies and whenever I'm traveling which
I do is really the next hobby I'll use
it and um I I'd just like to take
pictures because it gives you on the
idea of how well you can do with it and
to last thing I did was view nature um
and how we can actually see us or bear
giraffe I saw it and it just gives me
gives me time to concentrate and focus
on something completely different for
example that was a great experience to
we had with this cheetah here and I I
like really I'm to you know do something
very different more way more creative
I'd say then my daily business wonderful
yeah definitely we've just got time for
a couple of questions on our traditional
talking Germany quiz at the end of the
show yeah and here's an interesting
question for after all that has gone
before who's got the better chance in
life these days girls leaving Germany
schools or boys leaving Germany schools
I if if I judge maybe the the girls
right from the very objective point of
view they would have very good chances
if not the better ones but then maybe
equal ones am if we manage to ya make
our society fit for that then they would
talking of German society on women's
issues is Germany traditional or
progressive family tradition career and
children is it a woman's right or too
much to expect it's a woman's right
absolutely I think we'll leave it there
yeah that's all we have time for today
definitely thanks very much for being
our latest guess I'm talking Germany a
lot of interesting insights she's been
sharing with us her vision of the world
of work and the world of women if you've
enjoyed her company as much as I have to
come back next week and if you've missed
any shows as the archive if you want to
find out more check out my blog on the
internet site until next week bye bye
and just
you